yeah we need to talk about this
I'm so glad you bring it up
okay so in November
Florida residents are going to be able to vote in a ballot initiative
to protect abortion rights
in their state constitution
Republicans know that Americans in red states and in blue states
overwhelmingly support abortion access
they generally hate ballot initiatives
they do not want the issue of abortion to be in voters hands
they managed to stick some really gross language onto this ballot initiative
in a financial impact statement
telling Florida residents
that this initiative would result in fewer live earths in Florida per year
and at that may have a negative financial impact on the state
right off the bat they're literally just saying um
reproductive rights hinders our ability to control women's reproduction
which hinders our ability to capitalize on their unpaid reproductive labor
gross but it's also just completely wrong
to the extent that you're gonna put a financial impact statement
it should say something like
forcing families to birth children that they already have told you
that they can't afford has devastating financial impacts for families
are also just completely wrong
and trying to trick voters into thinking that
but denying abortions equals more babies
research shows it doesn't
men who are denied a wanted abortion
are much less likely to have a planned pregnancy later on
let's use an example let's say we have Emma and Sam
who are both pregnant and wants an abortion
Emma receives one Sam does not
Emma is much more likely to have planned pregnancies later off
Sam is not so Emma may go on to have three children
whereas Emma only has one
so they're trying to suggest to voters that if you deny women wanted abortions
we will see a nut increase in the state's population
and that's completely incorrect
the whole thing is literally so gross and ignorant and awful